senator tom cotton is on deck with us
today to weigh in on all of it he'll
join me moments from now
first let's go straight to the white
house our correspondent peter ducey is
there with more on the top story peter
harris good morning the american
federation of teachers got what they
wanted after sending this
email to the cdc that has now been
published by the new york post it said
in part
it would be great to see the insertion
some variation of the following
in the event high community transmission
results from a new variant of stars cove
to
a new update of the guidelines may be
necessary
and that last part in quotes wound up in
the official cdc guidance
records of political donations on
opensecrets.org find that the american
federation of teachers and their
affiliates donated
millions to liberal groups last cycle
and leadership claims they lobbied
trump officials last year more than
biden officials this year with this
quote the aft represents 1.7 million
educators health care professionals and
public employees
who spent the last 14 months serving on
the front lines of the kova 19 pandemic
so naturally we have been in regular
touch with the agencies setting policy
that affect their work
and lives including the cdc most states
moved teachers to the front of the line
for vaccines months ago but many have
resisted going back so far
and now republicans are pressuring the
president to send
them back i mean all the president has
to do is stand up and be very firm
the teachers aren't the problem it's
their leadership it's the teacher unions
i think the unions are holding out for
more pay in the
meantime our our children get hurt and
what's so
avoidable and and ashamed about all this
is the
president biden can fix it he says he
says he's the teach
the education president and a new york
times opinion piece today
makes the case that because school
reopenings affect parents ability to go
back to work and parenting
disproportionately parenting
responsibilities disproportionately fall
on women that reopening could become the
biggest
gender equality issue of the year harris
peter ducey thank you very much i want
to bring in senator tom cotton
republican from arkansas and let's get
started right there
senator you know is this a case of the
biden administration simply copying the
homework of the st
of the teachers union
harris it's good to be on with you the
cdc is a thoroughly politicized agency
most americans disregard their advice on
things like steaks and hamburgers and
beers
increasingly they should disregard their
advice when it comes to school reopening
schools need to be
open schools have been open in arkansas
five days a week in person
since last august and it's been largely
fine that's been the case all across the
country as well we shouldn't have a
politicized public health bureaucracy
like the cdc
answering at the beck and call of the
teachers unions we need
kids back in school and back in real
school not sitting in a classroom
doing a zoom session with teachers who
are not in the classroom
we need kids in schools with their
teachers
now i want to get to this and it has to
do with the mask wearing because we're
seeing some of that
mixed messaging from the president to
the united states
and him even getting some special
treatment he is the president they say
more protection than the rest of us who
are fully vaccinated
uh writer barry weiss wrote this masks
have become
a totem in the culture war there was no
virtue
being permanently masked there is no
in demanding zero risk if there were
we would never jump in a swimming pool
or get into a car
get vaccinated and then get used to
wearing hard pants
brushing your hair and your teeth and
meeting friends outside
of zoom senator cotton your reaction
dr fauci says we need to keep wearing
masks indefinitely dr fauci once again
is wrong almost half of all american
adults are now vaccinated
harris and it's been a couple weeks
since all americans became eligible so
by the end of may
anybody who wants a vaccine will have
had a chance to get it and to have it
become
fully effective there is zero reason to
be wearing masks
outdoors joe biden when he walks from
the white house to
the marine one helicopter should take
off his mask and show americans that
it's fine to start
getting back to normal we're
increasingly reaching the point harris
where people
are more worried about getting the
vaccine than they are worried about
getting an appointment for the vaccine
one way to encourage people to get the
vaccine would be to show that once you
have it
you can get back to your normal life you
don't have to wear a mask you don't have
to keep social distancing
you can go back to your normal
pre-coronavirus way of life
that's what most americans are hoping
for that's why people who
are vaccinated fully should take off the
masks and get back to normal
you know senator cotton it is so simple
to hear you say it
and it would be so simple to see if not
the president his team
do it i mean they're at these outdoor
events looking for his mask which he
took
off and he can't find i'm sure you saw
that video and everybody looking has on
a mask i mean it's
it's like you say way to sell it not
okay we'll move on
as president biden hits the road this
week senator he's trying to build
support for his massive spending plans
hillary clinton says
she's thrilled that president biden is
taking his agenda as far as possible
let's watch
it wasn't until the pandemic that i
think
a truly working majority of americans
crossing party lines as we've seen
because of the approval that republicans
and independent
voters are giving biden suddenly
understood
in a clear way that you know what
there's lots of times when we need the
government
this comes 25 years after her husband
president clinton famously declared
quote unquote the era of big government
is over
wow i i hear more mis mixed messaging
senator
yeah harris if hillary clinton is uh
praising the biden administration that's
probably a sign they're doing something
wrong
but you know what there are times when
the american people need the government
they need the government to protect our
borders
to stop illegal aliens from crossing at
record numbers
yet what has joe biden done he's totally
opened our borders
he's insisting that his uh public health
agencies
get more and more migrants into the
country as opposed to our border
security being able to stop them from
coming in the first place another time
that the american people need their
governments
are to protect them from crime we just
had a huge increase in the murder rate
the highest on record
yet joe biden the democrats continue to
attack the police as department of
justice is going on witch hunts against
police departments across the country
local prosecutors are refusing to
prosecute violent criminals democrats
are trying to pass more laws in congress
to let felons out of prison early those
are a couple times when the american
people
expect their government to protect them
and that's exactly the opposite of what
joe biden and the democrats are doing
senator it is great to have you on the
program today and i am very very glad to
get to this real quickly
a group of senate democrats are calling
on the president to
shut down the guantanamo bay prison and
president biden's secretary of state was
asked about it i can't wait to ask you
about it let's watch first
will the biden administration close
guantanamo bay
we believe that it should be that's
certainly a goal but it's something that
we'll bring some focus to in the months
ahead
senator i i know you have served we know
that we celebrate that service and that
sacrifice with you on this program
all the time when you look at what they
want to do with gitmo
what comes to mind
well i think they might want to treat
those guantanamo bay terrace the way
they treat illegal migrants coming to
our
country's border let them in and
probably then let them out but once they
get on american soil there's no telling
what a bunch of liberal lawyers will do
in court
but if those democratic senators want
guantanamo terrorists in the united
states
why don't we put them in their states
senator is there an unintended
consequence
of this that maybe the american people
should be aware of that the biden
administration isn't touching on
yeah there are more legal rights granted
those terrorists once they're on the
american mainland soil and there's no
telling what liberal judges will do or
what
uh joe biden's liberal department of
justice would allow
the safest place for those terrorists is
at guantanamo bay
look their tribunals should have been
completed long long ago
if it wasn't for liberal judges
intervening they would have been we also
have to be mindful that terrorism is
still a threat
and if we have operations where we
capture a lot of high value terrorists
in the future where are we going to put
them are we going to bring them to the
united states
or we're going to send them to some
other country or whether they may not
have the protections that they do have
at guantanamo bay gitmo is a perfectly
suitable place where
we've invested a lot of taxpayer dollars
to detain some of the world's most
dangerous terrorists that's where they
should stay
and that's where future detainees should
go
and i have read real quickly that you
know nothing recruits like people
inside the greatest country in the world
um
having that sort of liberal advocacy on
behalf of them
as you know they can talk they can
prophesize
yeah unfortunately you saw that was the
case with the blind shake in the first
world trade center bombing in 1993 that
he remained
an active and active proselytizer and
terrorist mastermind from federal prison
in the united states
senator cotton great state of arkansas
good to see you today thank you for your
time
thank you harris